STEVE PERRY: In a small
Silicon Valley office,
Salman Khan is using simple
illustrations and lingo
to explain math, science,
history, and even business
concepts.
SALMAN KHAN: If this
does not blow your mind,
then you have no emotion.
STEVE PERRY: The 10 to 20-minute
tutorials on khanacademy.org
are free to anyone, anywhere.
Sal.
You have found the answer, man.
SALMAN KHAN: Hopefully.
We've got a lot of work to do.
STEVE PERRY: No, I'm serious.
You've opened up the world
of learning to the world.
SALMAN KHAN: The best way to
get at the core of most issues--
whether it's poverty,
health care, whatever,
even democracy-- is making
sure you have an educated
population.
And so the technology
is now making it
so that the delivery
cost of that education
is going pretty close to 0.
DEAN BRETTLE: Instead you get
31 instead of negative 31.
STEVE PERRY: Dean
Brettle uses Khan Academy
as a tool for homeschooling
his two children.
DEAN BRETTLE: What
I like about it
and what I think the
kids like about it
is that you can work
at your own pace.
If they don't understand the
video, they can pause it.
They can rewind it.
They can watch it
multiple times.
CHILD: Seven.
DEAN BRETTLE: And you've
already got the 2's.
STEVE PERRY: And
with Khan, you have
to master all the
material before moving on,
with only hints to help you.
DEAN BRETTLE: If you're
struggling with something
in a regular school,
and you don't get it
but you take the
test, and you get--
STEVE PERRY: A C.
DEAN BRETTLE: A C on the test.
STEVE PERRY: Can't
move on with a C here.
DEAN BRETTLE: That's right.
STEVE PERRY: You trying
to kick teachers out?
Because that's what a lot of
teachers then start to think.
SALMAN KHAN: No, it's
the complete opposite.
What it does, at
least in my mind,
it would make the job of
teaching a lot more fun.
Because they come in
every day and they
get to actually be guides and
mentors for these students.
STEVE PERRY: Like fifth
grade teacher Richard Julian.
His Los Altos, California
school uses Khan lessons
in math class.
The software tracks
each student's progress.
RICHARD JULIAN: And by doing
that it allows the teacher
to know their
students very well.
It allows them to
know their strengths.
know their weaknesses.
STEVE PERRY: Khan
Academy is a nonprofit.
But it's backed by
Bill Gates and Google.
You could make money
from this, you know.
[SALMAN LAUGHS]
You can make a lot of money.
How many distinct users
do you have per month?
SALMAN KHAN: It's
pushing two million now.
STEVE PERRY: You're
the math guy,
but $1 apiece isn't
that much to charge.
You're doing this
for free, partner.
What gives?
SALMAN KHAN: You know, if
Khan Academy was for profit,
it would limit the number
of kids who would use it.
Hopefully when I'm
80, I can say, wow,
there's a billion
kids that use it,
and maybe will
continue to use it.
And maybe even
after I'm gone, this
can be an institution
that can last
for 100 years or 200 years.